[Music]
we should get willy wonka make it happen
oh yeah
which is uh timmy one coming timothy c
to lotham chalamet
tilapia
oh is there no trailer this is just a
picture yeah it's like oh i thought they
did like a theatrical or like a teaser i
mean
i guess this is a prequel just wonka
i guess we learned the story of how we
earned the name willy wonka
it's just gonna be this is gonna be a
rip of um
call me by her name
yeah
it's gonna be some really high art willy
wonka yeah i get it now finally
really high art at the end of it he's
going to pull his dick out and then some
girls will be like
i am willy you smell like willy
i am willy that's not gonna stop
bothering me that is a quote from
something i am
i am the lost
what do you think wonka
bleed i am
women only nap
yeah women only now okay nice
women only nap
women only nap knowing anxiety
nice
so women always sleep
wonka wonka nice timothy chalamet says
wonka is not mining the
darker emotions in life
it's a celebration of being off center
and of being okay with the weirder parts
of you that don't quite fit in willy
what do you want to be when you grow up
i want to create a chocolate factory
underground
with little people in it
[Music]
okay okay don't you just want to be a
youtuber like every other kid
you get there by boat right
like what about accounting like
or
now he's talking about his dick
the weirder parts of you that don't
quite fit in oh yeah that's what yes
that's why they call him willy wonka
it's like some like greek [ __ ] like
everyone's got extremely micros yeah and
they're just bagging on them ah look at
walkers willie no i'm the big willie
they call me horse dick
ew get away from me horse dick oh it's a
musical
upcoming musical let's yeah
oh wait the original was too right
yeah is that was that considered to be
just all the
the only people singing were the oompa
loompas right i can't remember any of
them was there a lot of songs
like what
oh like i am a chocolate man right
yeah oh yeah there's that one that was
like
yeah my ap going psycho oh
yeah that [ __ ]
yeah that was interesting yeah warner
brothers go ahead and keep that film we
don't need it
we don't need it that in this new sweet
home alone
the harry potter
the hair the harry potterizing of home
alone we don't [ __ ] need that
harry potter eyes
it's like an english kid is the main
character we don't need it macaulay
culkin did the service as
kevin mcallister
hollywood already tried this with that
other random white kid we don't care
there's only one white kid we want to
see terrorizing burglars
there's macaulay culkin at seven years
old everything else [ __ ] keep it we
don't need it
i don't want another willy wonka i like
the johnny depp one
i like that one he's not the new johnny
depp timothy chalamet
oh i don't know i haven't seen any of
his movies so timmy you know seeing
timmy's films timmy's work i want to see
dune though i'm going to go see it
probably on friday in a theater yeah oh
yeah no maybe not
i'm you know i love theaters like you
know you know me you know me i love me a
good
theater dinner oh yeah i love having
dinner in the movie oh yeah
little theater dog yeah
t-dog the candyman cam oh this song this
song i hated this [ __ ] let's turn up for
a second let's turn it off triple cream
casserole got a new one
who can take a sunrise i hate this
[ __ ] no rose
this is the original i know this is the
original but i'm talking about the
oh we all watched i never watched this
one i don't think are you 1971 you
thought would i have watched this
are you
you're really confident i don't watch
old [ __ ] dude you this was the staple
like because this is a book
dude you need to watch this this movie
is [ __ ] up this was like the era of
hollywood when they just like killed
people to make movies so the original is
like not a children's movie it's kind of
creepy no it's like children's movie but
everything about it is [ __ ] creepy
this [ __ ] when augustus gloop gets stuck
in the tube yeah is the single most
horrifying film they just used to run
this [ __ ] on loop to like us as
seven-year-olds everyone's freaking out
like can that really happen to you and
they're like yes yeah
your daycare people are like yes it will
if you don't shut the [ __ ] up yeah if
you speak we'll put you in a tube like
augustus glue oh i've seen this 100 i've
[ __ ] seen this yeah that's why i'm
like just seen this oh my god i've seen
this 5 000 times you're lying i swear to
god what's wrong with me also that's not
chocolate dude yeah it looks like that's
straight up blood the colorist had a
nightmare experience on this just
drowning
like just full-on drowning now he's not
i guess oh no terrific pressure watch
what happens help help his head just
explodes yeah bro
no way that was it
raided our wonka oh boy rated r willy
wonka what inside this room all of my
dreams become reality that's blood
that's straight up blood yeah
[Laughter]
the human remains
oh that's why they made it more red he
can't swim
watch the pipe
i could have sworn there was more
struggle on this
terrific well this is how i remember it
oh my god
what the [ __ ] is
[Music]
you terrible man
[Music]
you terrible man oh my god shout out to
corridor bro corridor shouts to him for
making that that was incredible him bro
corridor is like 25 people
damn whatever
okay jeez what is that channel oh it's a
vfx studio yeah they do okay
corridor
captain kirk i don't care all of you
shut the [ __ ] up i'm trying to talk to
shanice
we don't need a movie about not being
weird or like being okay to be
it's like we have enough and timothy
chalamet is the guy he's not a weirdo
he's [ __ ] mgk and megan fox calling
themselves outcasts we're such outcasts
yeah we like you know we like to make
make it known that like you can be weird
it's so hard being weed it's so hard
being weed all the time you know
everyone's just like wow you're so weak
it's like
i'm not
yeah i'm weed but i'm not just weed it's
really hard and everyone wants to like
have sex with you yeah okay
it undermines your feelings